i termini più importati che voglio
evidenziare sono il fare ancora meglio
saper fare e poi la parola passione che
in tutto il mondo e in tutti i mondi
possibili può veramente essere uno
straordinario motore di cambiamento
intorno alla passione ci si può
raggruppare ci si può ritrovare
con accomunati dalla voglia di fare
delle cose e magari farle anche con
piacere perché è dimostrato
che
divertendosi è più facile accettare il
cambiamento questo è un approccio
tedesco nella fun theory finanziato
dalla dalla volkswagen mentre
l'approccio americano ci fa vedere in
maniera molto più concreta qual è
l'andamento del mercato delle stampanti
3d si legge immediatamente questa
accelerazione esponenziale della
del mercato americano
queste questi questi sistemi questo
questi processi hanno delle implicazioni
sociali quali sono le sfide sottese a
queste accelerazioni sociali assistiamo
e veniamo da un sistema in cui una
produzione
centralizzata
produce oggetti per un consumo di massa
parliamo di mass media che diffondono
dei bisogni che vengono generalmente
imposti e non in non in una maniera
interattiva parliamo di televisione
parliamo di mondo analogico la rete
aggiunge oggi e questa è la grande
novità che viene portata da internet
introduce questa grande quantità di
informazioni e la possibilità di
interagire
nello stesso tempo i costi ridotti per
la prototipazione rapida e tutto un
sistema che aiuta il singolo il privato
nello sviluppare le proprie idee portano
ad un modello ibrido che è stato
chiamato
prosumer prosumer è un soggetto che
ibrido che consuma una parte di quello
che produce i makers sono fanno parte di
questa categoria forse tutti voi avrete
sentito parlare di make us è una parola
molto usata soprattutto in questi in
questi tempi e ci sono molte definizioni
a me piace raccontare che cosa sono i
make us la mia idea di makers facendo
parlare due oggetti conoscerete la lima
questo un oggetto antico e questa è una
lima e questo invece è una lima di un
maker
vedete tutti
la differenza sta in questa piegatura
qui si vede ed è evidente questa
determinazione il carattere di un maker
di una persona che fa le cose nel
plasmare la tecnica e gli strumenti che
ha a disposizione senza subirle senza
subire l'inibizione della tecnologia in
questo caso c'è un bisogno e il mac erba
direttamente velocemente a soddisfare il
bisogno la la sua necessità pur e per
farlo è disposto a piegare l'acciaio in
questo caso l'esigenza era quella di
piallare il piano un piano nel centro
mio nonno era un maker
guardate come
cosa è riuscito a combinare con la mia
piccola bicicletta da bambino
trasformata in un motorino
tutti siamo un po makers questo è un
articolo un ritaglio di un giornale di
domenica scorsa che
fa fa vedere come emerge da un'indagine
per la cna che il 51 per cento degli
italiani fa le piccole riparazioni
casalinghe da solo
tutti qui credo o molti di voi avranno
nonno un padre che ha l'officina un
piccolo laboratorio in garage
è il mondo del ii iii del fai da te che
a me piace più
tradurre con il termine questo l'ho
fatto io perché aggiunge anche un po di
soddisfazione far le cose questo è
quello che succede nelle officine nei
laboratori aggiungiamo il potere della
rete i networks
a questo punto il questo l'ho fatto io
diventa questo lo abbiamo fatto noi e in
noi
aggiunge un'implicazione di luogo
i fab lab sono proprio dei luoghi di
aggregazione dove ci si può trovare per
fare delle cose sono dei laboratori come
l'officina
tradizionali ma rispetto alle officine
sono aperti al pubblico quindi si può
venire si possono affittare le macchine
di fabbricazione digitale si possono
richiedere delle competenze aggiuntive
per soddisfare le proprie le proprie
esigenze e per costruire o produrre le
proprie idee in più c'è il valore della
rete tutti i fab lab sono connessi a una
rete internazionale di più di 200
località nel mondo
nate alle mighty di boston hanno tutti
un codice comune è una serie di
competenze di tecnologie
codificate
e però lasciano libero ogni laboratorio
di svilupparsi e di assumere il
carattere specifico del territorio in
cui si inserisce nel nostro caso noi
abbiamo un grande vantaggio che il
contesto in cui ci troviamo
esprime un grande grandi livelli di
qualità nella cultura nella nelle
relazioni e nelle eccellenze espressa
anche dalla dall'industria
il fab lab di reggio emilia nasce
all'interno di uno spazio per l'arte
contemporanea allo spazio gerra
che lo caratterizza subito con una
peculiarità che quella di avere
un'apertura e un rapporto diretto con il
pubblico e con le istituzioni per cui
fin da subito è stato riconosciuto il
laboratorio un valore proprio nell
innovazione sociale più che non negli
aspetti di innovazione tecnologica
dall'inizio abbiamo subito ho visto le
potenzialità del fab lab e in questo
senso si è costruito e si sta costruendo
una grande community di persone
eterogenee che partecipano all la nostra
attività programmate tra cui il worshop
prest che stimolano la conoscenza e la
diffusione della stampa 3d di tutto
quello che è legato alla manifattura
additiva alla robotica
alla interaction design attraverso
l'applicazione di open source quindi
scheda open source come la scheda
arduino
oppure applicazioni legate a dei
caratteri più specifici per esempio la
moda e l'utilizzo di feltro laser cut ed
quindi taglio laser oppure applicazioni
nella musica per il controllo e
l'interazione delle interfacce musicali
in questa rete partecipa anche
l'università il corso di industrial
design che appena nato all'università di
modena e reggio dipartimento di
meccatronica e
ingegneria gestionale
tutte queste cose tutti questi sistemi
queste persone contribuiscono a
costruire un panorama di oggetti molto
interessante e vario ma soprattutto
costruiscono delle relazioni e le
relazioni offrono delle opportunità
opportunità vengono aumentate a livello
esponenziale per il fatto che comunque i
fab lab sono una costituiscono una rete
per cui il talento che si esprime a
livello locale ha un'opportunità una
finestra una uno spazio di visibilità
anche a livello nazionale e
internazionale come ha dimostrato la
maker faire dove sono stati presentati
dei progetti di makers reggiani modenesi
il nostro ruolo in tutto questo è quello
di
mettere a sistema tutti questi valori e
fare in modo che gli ingranaggi girano
girino e e non si sprechino delle
opportunità cerchiamo di costruire delle
alleanze virtuose fra che mettano in
contatto i talenti e makers con le
aziende i bisogni specifici delle
aziende per questo abbiamo lanciato un
programma che si chiama mac solutions
che intende indagare alcuni aspetti
emersi che emergono nelle competenze
distintive del nostro territorio che
sono quelle elencate in alto allo stesso
modo vogliamo dare l'opportunità e
cerchiamo di stimolare la nascita di
start up innovative
mettendoli in contatto con i sistemi le
reti che possono possono favorire il
reperimento di finanze quindi
crowdfunding oppure di utilizzare delle
piattaforme open source per la vendita
degli oggetti né per la loro diffusione
considerate che oggi è possibile
progettare un oggetto qui a bologna
spedire il file dall'altra parte del
mondo e assistere in tempo reale alla
produzione dell'oggetto
nel luogo in cui viene verrà utilizzato
questo processo è potenzialmente
rivoluzionario anche perché riduce
drasticamente le due voci che sono
quelle del retail e del brand che
contribuiscono alla composizione del
prezzo di vendita in questo modo noi
abbiamo non abbiamo più trasporto
abbiamo la logistica molto
ridimensionata abbiamo probabilmente dei
soldi delle risorse in più per investire
nella ricerca che invece l'aspetto su
cui
ultimamente recentemente si è sempre
tagliato
a livello sociale l'impatto socio
economico questo sistema potrebbe
favorire e lo sta facendo in parte
stiamo assistendo e verificando questo
fenomeno alla trasformazione di un
sistema produttivo centralizzato in un
sistema diffuso di produzione diffusa di
micro factory in cui ogni singolo
portatore diciamo di idee può fare
impresa ea un sistema collaborativo che
lo aiuta a farlo e fra questi anche gli
spazi come il fab lab e maker space è
una situazione che potrebbe in parte
richiedere una revisione anche di questo
che un diagramma su cui si sono basate i
siti basati sistemi industriali
tradizionali quella del break even point
dove la re di profitto è in un punto
molto alto che prevede la produzione di
un alto numero di prodotti prima di di
verificarsi e
invece potrebbe essere condizionato da
questa nuova teoria che quella della
long tail proposta è raccontata molto
bene da andersen nel libro makers che
invece dimostra come è possibile
produrre degli oggetti
da un costo competitivo anche con delle
piccole partite e favorendo la
customizzazione quindi la
personalizzazione dell'oggetto
sull'utente finale
in tutto questo crediamo che ci sia
molto da fare non cavalchiamo la curva
del del ted della
dell'accelerazione esponenziale però
vogliamo farlo in una filosofia molto
makers molto concreta misurando passo
dopo passo e lasciando aperto al ad un
aspetto che crediamo molto importante
che quello dell'imprevedibilità che può
essere veramente un campo straordinario
di sperimentazione dell'innovazione
grazie